do you feel like uh
in today's
landscape of artists
there's
another guy who kind of reminds you or
gives you the energy of kevin gates
that's out there
everybody's great in their own right
i don't even look at it like that
anymore
but everybody's great in their own right
whose energy do you appreciate right now
a new artist i don't even listen to a
lot of rap
so you got to forgive me what do you
listen to
god
god
y'all listen to god he's diamond for
sure yeah i listen that guy but
i listen at a lot of rock and roll
like soft rock
oldies
not oldest but like 90s
like rock yeah so like uh
when you say soft rock 90s like dave
matthews band or like i know about dave
matthews band but
i like is and then i'm not a fan of a
whole
uh um a whole group of people i'm just a
whole collection of the music it's just
like certain songs like a playlist like
say if i'm jogging it's gonna be
one of my playlists started i took her
out
it was a friday night
like that yeah then it might go from
there to
uh i shun then woulda haven't you people
ever heard of closing the goddamn door
no it's much better to face these sorts
of things with this poison personality
panic down this panic at the disco oh no
it's panic at the disco so it just my my
playlist is weird
yo who i would have never have thought
that you're a panic at the disco blink
182 guy i like the word play panic at
this i like they they were playing that
was a great era of rock that i like
green day too green day is great another
turning point the fox look in the road
time grabs you by the wrist directs you
here to go
and memories are lasting on trial
for what it's worth it was worth all the
while
something unpredictable but in the end
is right i hope you had the time of your
life it just i don't know it's just it's
like when you running
you get lost cause it's like you just
get lost
yo that's i'm weird i love green no you
know we're great but listen great days
are the biggest bands ever they had uh
you know green day had a broadway play
for like five years about one of their
albums
so that's uh that's that's that's dope
but it's just it's just like when i'm on
a treadmill running
it's like
that's that
we going a distance have you ever
experienced any of that music live as a
fan
oh one time
one time
who'd you see live
uh
i forgot
i was at this atlantic
party
[Music]
and
dude was up there playing the guitar and
everything it wasn't ed sheeran he was
it was another dude but he played the
guitar he played every instrument and
sang and i was like man this fly
i only remember his name